[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
l'hebdo vingt dix minutes pour revenir
sur l'essentiel de l'actualité de la
semaine
au sommaire de ce vendredi 22 novembre
deux associations pour une journée
nationale les sciences de l'ingénieur au
féminin objectif démontrer aux jeunes
filles que l'ingénierie n'est pas
réservé aux garçons
reportage à suivre collège alexandre
dumas de maurepas après l'immolation
d'un étudiant devant le crous de lyon le
8 novembre dernier
ils sont nombreux à dénoncer la
précarité qu'ils subissent nous ferons
le point avec le vice président étudiant
de l'université versailles saint quentin
en yvelines le premier ministre et la
ministre du travail a lui en cours la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur a
lu vs qu est le haut-commissaire
retraite à vélizy cette semaine les
event accueilli deux hautes
personnalités de l'état et pour débuter
cette édition une nouvelle étape dans la
fusion des départements des yvelines des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine jeudi le
comité du syndicat mixte ouvert et ville
numérique a entériné l'adhésion des
hauts-de-seine le premier opérateur
interdépartemental à la disposition des
collectivités s'appellera désormais
c'est mme evelyne numérique
nous avons trouvé grâce à la
constitution de ce syndicat et après un
appel d'offres un prestataire qui ne
coûte rien aux départements
tdf qui est en train de se déployer sur
l'ensemble du département des yvelines
donc puisque ce déploiement se passe
bien puisque nous avons le projet de
nous rapprocher avec les hauts-de-seine
il est maintenant logique que les
hauts-de-seine et qui ont leur propre
réseau de fibre avec une autre société
puisse venir dans le syndicat numérique
ce que ça va changer c'est que sur mon
différentes compétences en matière de
services numériques pour l'éducation
vidéoprotection et d'autres compétences
à venir ultérieure nous allons
travailler sur une assiette beaucoup
plus large et donc beaucoup plus
pertinente avec à la fois plus de
richesse en termes de remontée de
terrain mais aussi une meilleure
mutualisation et une meilleure
efficacité des projets que nous mettons
ce qui est intéressant c'est que si on
double le territoire on ne double pas
les effectifs on voit donc très bien les
effets de la mutualisation et l'identité
visuelle de séné vie numérique sera
dévoilée le 17 décembre
[Musique]
les femmes ne sont que 21% à être
ingénieur pour pallier ce chiffre les
associations elles bougent et l'union
des professeurs de sciences et
techniques industrielles ont lancé une
journée nationale les sciences de
l'ingénieur au féminin la 7ème édition
se tenait jeudi 21 novembre 18 mille
jeunes femmes ont été sensibilisés comme
celle au collège alexandre dumas demeure
pas aurélie rose s'est glissé parmi l
ingénieur c'est aussi pour les femmes
pour certaines de ces 80 élèves de 4e
c'était une découverte leur collège
participé à la septième journée
nationale des sciences de l'ingénieur au
féminin il y a qu une minorité de femmes
qui font ce genre de métier et pour dire
que c'est aussi accessible pour les
femmes on connaissait juste des hommes
j'ai jamais connu de faire une erreur
comme témoin des femmes ingénieures
sahara nédélec et chef de service chez
bout de travaux et public
elle se déplace dans les collèges
franciliens depuis quatre ans c'est très
important parce que moi je me rappelle
quand j'ai commencé je il y avait
peut-être 5% des femmes dans ces métiers
là
et
c'est pas normal normalement
dans les entreprises il doit y avoir une
représentation équitable de la société
les femmes sont autant compétente que
des angles le collège de maurepas
participé pour la première fois cette
journée trois heures d'échangés avec des
questions sur le salaire sur l'égalité
entre hommes et femmes et sur les choix
d'orientation peut-être qu'elle ne se
questionne pas encore mais nous on
aimerait voilà que elle se questionne
qu'elle commence à se questionner parce
qu'effectivement en fin de 3e fera faire
un choix d'orientation s'est jamais long
et difficile quand on aime ce qu'on fait
et des fois bien effectivement j'ai
aussi expliqué qu'il ya des moments on
peut se tromper on peut faire un choix
se tromper et puis bien changé c'est pas
grave on a le droit à l'erreur cette
journée concerne près de 20000 jeune
fille sur l'année 2017 2018
les femmes n'étaient que 27% dans les
formations d'ingénieurs
[Musique]
je veux pas ici commenté ce qu'a fait
cet étudiant il ya d'abord une enquête
qui est en cours
il ya sa souffrance celle de sa famille
mais elle nous rappelle sans nous le
faire découvrir les difficultés de la
vie étudiante les difficultés auxquelles
notre jeunesse est aussi confrontée
aujourd'hui quand ella a étudié parfois
travailler quand elle doute de l'avenir
le 8 novembre dernier un étudiant de
lyon s'immolait par le feu devant le
crous de son université avant de passer
à l'acte il avait posté un long message
sur son compte facebook dénonçant les
conditions de vie des étudiants
d'après une enquête de l'insee en 2016
20,8 pour cent des étudiants se situer
sous le seuil de pauvreté contre 12 8%
de la population
quatre jours après cette tentative de
suicide des étudiants manifester contre
cette précarité étudiante
une intersyndicale a appelé à une
nouvelle manifestation le 26 novembre
prochain pour demander un plan d'urgence
pierre-antoine suarez vous êtes le
vice-président étudiant de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
c'est vous qui représentez les étudiants
au comité de direction de lever est ce
qu je précise aussi que vous êtes
représentant du syndicat la fage à lui
est ce qu bonjour bonjour alors cette
précarité étudiante est ce que vous l'a
constaté à le dsq on la constate oui la
précarité étudiante et on l'a on la
voile ne serait ce que par le fait qu'il
y ait des étudiants boursiers c'est dû
rembourser ses déceptions qu'on connaît
après il ya toute une précarité qu'on ne
connaît pas je parle des étudiants
internationaux qui eux n'ont pas accès à
la bourse et dont on sait qu'ils vivent
en situation de précarité
il ya tous ces étudiants qui qu'on
n'arrive pas à toucher malgré les
dispositifs que qui sont développés par
l'ue vs cul et par le crous et par les
différentes agences sociales de l'état
on la constate au jour le jour il ya de
la précarité partout et la précarité
pour le logement et la grippe la
précarité pour se nourrir pour l'accès
aux soins
il ya la précarité qui fait que les
étudiants se mettent à travailler parce
que sinon ils ne peuvent pas survivre
pendant leurs études tout ça c'est pour
moi ce sont des agents de précarité on
va prendre justement ces points je vais
parler du logement
fin août le syndicat étudiant unef
publié son classement annuel des villes
selon le cours de la vie étudiante
un calcul à partir d'un socle commun
fixe sur les coûts de base
logement et les transports il en
ressortait que guyancourt serait la
quatrième ville la plus chère avec des
dépenses mensuelles moyennes d'un
étudiant 2000 66 euros 65 et un loyer
moyen de 670 euros
comment font les étudiants il ya un plus
intérêt à peu près un étudiant sur deux
qui ce salary déjà donc ça pour moi
c'est un facteur qui qui qui handicapent
la réussite des étudiants il ya des
étudiants qui ont recours au recours aux
bourses et des étudiants qui ce salary
hauteur de 35 heures par semaine en plus
de leurs études
il y en a qui s'endettent aussi il ya on
voit de tout justement d'après une
enquête sur les conditions de vie des
étudiants en 2016 sont 46% à travailler
vous l'avez un peu avec un peu évoqué le
salariat étudiant ça peut mettre en
péril ses études bien sûr quand on passe
entre 15 ou moins même mais jusqu'à 35
heures de son temps hors étude sur un
emploi c'est 35 heures en moins qu'on
n'a pas pour aller dans les
amphithéâtres pour aller dans les
travaux dirigés ou dans les travaux
pratiques
ces 35 heures en moins qu'on n'a pas sur
le temps pour réussir ses études pour
voir étudier dans de bonnes conditions
est ce que finalement ce coût de la vie
étudiante remet pas un peu en cause le
principe d'égalité des chances à
l'université
bien sûr à partir du moment où il ya des
étudiants qui arrivent et qui n'ont pas
besoin de ces salariés des étudiants qui
arrivent et avec et qui sont issus de
familles qui parlaient qui permettent de
les héberger et qui ont un repas chaud
tous les soirs et tous les midis qui
peuvent en plus quand un petit déjeuner
le matin et à partir du moment où il ya
de l'autre côté des étudiants qui s'y
qui n'ont pas accès à des soins
réguliers et qui peuvent pas laisser
dentiste parce que ça coûte cher ou
qu'ils renoncent à se faire soigner pour
des problèmes optique de deux yeux en
tout cas parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
fonds pour pouvait survenir
oui c'est une rupture d'égalité des
chances alors cette semaine des as tu as
reçu la visite de frédéric vidal la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
elle a notamment découvert l'épicerie
solidaire qui est mise en place à
l'effet est ce qu on regarde ce
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude la précarité
étudiante au centre de la visite de
frédéric vidal à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
s'est rendue dans l'agora une épicerie
sociale et solidaire installé
d'ailleurs de la faculté gérés par des
étudiants évidemment le rôle épicerie et
le rôle solidaire est très important
mais je crois qu est ce qu il faut pas
oublier c'est le mot social c'est aussi
un endroit où les étudiants qui parfois
parce qu'ils viennent de quitter leur
famille se retrouve seul et bien peuvent
échanger peuvent partager les choses on
néglige trop souvent la question de la
solitude et la précarité ça enferme
aussi dans la solitude l'épicerie
ouverte depuis septembre 2018 a dû en
cours proposent des produits
alimentaires et d'hygiène
les tarifs entre 10 et 20% du prix du
marché on voit que la ministre ait
touché par par ce qui se passe par ces
actions là qu'elle les soutient et donc
ça pourrait encore faim comment dire
favoriser le développement aussi
d'autres d'autres tags oreilles
heures et puis d'autres structures en
règle générale pour aider les étudiants
la ministre est également venu pour
annoncer officiellement la création d'un
numéro d'urgence
objectif aider les jeunes à mieux
connaître les aides j'ai encore de
constater ici ce qu'on me dit c'est la
difficulté pour un jeune qui se trouve
dans une situation de précarité peu
importe qu'elle soit soudaine ou qu'elle
soit constante et c'est donc mettre en
place ce numéro d'urgence c'est une
façon de dire aux jeunes
vous pouvez téléphoner et ensuite on va
s'occuper de vous et vous diriger vers
les bonnes personnes et le numéro
d'urgence devrait être actif d'ici la
fin de l'année selon l'observatoire de
la vie étudiante 5% les étudiants sont
en situation de précarité
pierre-antoine suarez les étudiants ils
se montrent solidaires à l'image de
cette épicerie
il ya d'autres initiatives qui sont
mises en place comme celle ci il esquive
étudiante
oui il y en a quelques-unes il ya une
autre association du vs quick a mis en
place un potager solidaire et qui a mis
en place des appels des cages adverses
en fait c'est une amap qui ont réussi a
sollicité par des producteurs locaux et
qui se déplacent directement au sein de
l'ufr des sciences sociales et de liste
aei il propose des paniers à 2 5 kg tout
les toutes les semaines maintenant à
hauteur de pour 3 euros c'est un prix de
revient pour les étudiants une
solidarité à un thème dans le reportage
à la ministre annonce l'ouverture d'un
numéro d'urgence pour mieux connaître
les aides auxquelles ont droit les
étudiants alimente de ces
informations-là des étudiants aventures
de ces informations là oui mais
peut-être ce qui ce qui manque davantage
qu'une ligne deux numéros d'urgence pour
faire connaître ces informations là ce
sont des moyens humains derrière qui
vont pouvoir traiter les demandes des
étudiants et les accompagner nous ce qui
ce qu'on se compensent en tout cas nous
les représentants étudiants c'est que on
manque de
on manque de premiers contacts vis-à-vis
des étudiants qui sont issus des
situations précarité parce que c'est des
étudiants qui vont - l'université donc
qu'ils consultent au mans les
responsables illustratif et des
enseignants en règle générale c'est des
étudiants auxquels on a auprès desquels
on a du mal à avoir des contacts
finalement m cette ligne d'urgence et
mettre un petit pansement mais c'est pas
soigné l'hémorragie qu'il ya depuis
longtemps confié tout à l'heure au cc
qu'il faut identifier cette précarité
voilà tout à fait il faut il faut savoir
d'où elle vient il faut savoir y
apporter une réponse juste et adaptée et
aujourd'hui les aides qui sont proposés
par les crous sont sont insatisfaisantes
et ou en tout cas suffisante
merci pierre antoine d'être venu sur le
plateau on arrive à la fin cet entretien
je le rappelle vous êtes vice président
des étudiants à l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines un métier sur
2 évoluera proches paiement d'ici dix
ans
le gouvernement met en place un nouveau
service public pour trouver des offres
de formation de façon simplifiée via une
application mon compte formation a été
lancée jeudi au campus des services de
l'automobile de l'automobile et de la
mobilité par muriel pénicaud ministre du
travail
edwards fait le premier ministre au
portage de manon varaldo muriel pénicaud
ministre du travail et edouard philippe
premier ministre ont lancé l'application
mon compte formation campus des services
de l'automobile et de la mobilité à
guyancourt
cette application permet de s'inscrire
directement en formation sans passer par
un intermédiaire l'objectif faire
décoller la formation professionnelle en
france
il ya simplement une personne sur trois
qui vont en formation chaque année il ya
beaucoup plus d'aspiration évaluer et
puis ya beaucoup plus ce souci
d'évolution des métiers on sait qu'on
avait en france un accès à la formation
professionnelle qui était très en deçà
des besoins très en dessous de ce qu'on
pouvait faire
et probablement parce qu'il y avait des
gens qui ne connaissaient pas leurs
droits
mon compte formation permet de connaître
ses droits à des formations puis de
trouver de réserver et de payer la
formation de son choix
sa patte vous
métier sur l'entreprise pour un
demandeur d'emploi s'est trouvé un
emploi il avec une qualification on a
trois fois plus de chances de trouver un
emploi
l'application est ouverte à tous les
salariés et demandeurs d'emploi patrick
pereira salarié d'une entreprise de
déménagement souhaitent se former au
parmi pour chariots élévateurs
il s'inscrit en direct avec son numéro
de sécurité sociale son email et en
créant un mot de passe je fais partie et
c'est parti le nombre d'inscriptions est
là l'organisme de formation à 48 heures
pour répondre
le compte est crédité de 500 euros par
an 800 pour les salariés non qualifiés
les formations diplômantes ou
certifiantes tourne autour des 1400
euros
il est pas très courant qu'on dise à 25
millions de français c'est beaucoup
quand même 25 millions de français vous
avez un droit et vous ne l'exercé pas
aujourd'hui mais grâce à ça vous allez
pouvoir l'exercer
plus de 100000 formations sont proposées
actuellement sur mon compte formation et
après la formation professionnelle la
retraite pour faire de la pédagogie sur
le projet de réforme en cours
le haut-commissaire retraite jean paul
delevoye s'est rendu à vélizy lundi une
réunion publique où la centaine de
personnes présentes a pu poser des
questions et interpeller le monsieur
retraites du gouvernement une réforme
toujours en débat sur laquelle certains
points sont encore en réflexion
jean paul delevoye au micro de nicolas
d'andré quand on est dans l'universalité
des droits c'est les mêmes règles pour
tous un métier l'antique retraite
identique et tout ce qui ne justifie pas
une spécificité une particularité comme
les artisans les commerçants les
professions libérales ou les professions
mais gallienne qui est sur notre
sécurité
tout cela intégrera le régime universel
ça c'est un vrai débat vous savez entre
l'âge de déquilibre que j'ai proposé et
celles et ceux qui souhaiteraient une
durée de cotisation individuelle
c'est en cours de débat ceci sera
tranchée d'ici la fin d'année
ils s'alarment d'un hôpital public à
bout de souffle les personnels soignants
des hôpitaux mener une journée de
mobilisation jeudi 14 novembre entre
7000 et dix mille personnes par exemple
défiler dans la rue à paris dans les
yvelines aussi les hôpitaux se sont
mobilisés au centre hospitalier de
poissy saint germain
et à l'hôpital françois quesnay 2 montre
la jolie est ce que vous voyez à l'image
à l'hôpital andré mignot du chesnay un
représentant syndical de ce dernier
étaient en plateau du 7-8 journal mardi
soir le demande le personnel hospitalier
ce sont des moyens donc du budget des
augmentations de salaires de nos
salaires sont gelés depuis dix ans enfin
c'est juste plus possible de vivre
aujourd'hui on survit les agents de
manque 300 euros minimum d'augmentation
et pas des primes de l'augmentation
et puis on demande du personnel on
manque de personnel ils ont piteux on
est au service minimum tous les jours
c'est plus possible de continuer comme
ça enfin on a eu des vagues dessus ici
là depuis quelques années et on peut pas
continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions là c'était intenable
mercredi le premier ministre edouard
philippe et la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn présenter leur plan
d'urgence pour l'hôpital notamment 1,5
milliard d'euros supplémentaires sur
trois ans dont 300 millions d'aidé 2020
la reprise en partie de la dette des
hôpitaux à hauteur de 10 milliards sur
trois ans et plusieurs primes pour le
personnel soignant
des annonces qui ne conviennent pas
plusieurs syndicats et collectifs
ils attendaient une hausse nette des
salaires et confirme la journée de
mobilisation prévue le 30 novembre une
nouvelle le 17 décembre un mode économie
à présent plus de 700 entreprises
rassemblées au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour la
quatrième édition du skype business dès
jeudi une convention d'affaires pour
faciliter les rencontres entre grandes
entreprises tpe pme et start-up
territoire des rendez vous d'affaires
qui s'enchaînent un village de
l'innovation pour découvrir les
nouvelles idées des start up
le tout dans diverses compétences de
l'aéronautique au tourisme on est là
pour pour conserver aussi pour pour que
les entreprises de saint quentin elles
sont dix sept mille je crois et bien
elle travaille encore plus ensemble et
que surtout les les petits puissent plus
facilement avoir accès aux gros parce
que c'est quand même deux mondes
différents pour accès pour avoir accès à
une boîte du cac 40 comme une petite
boîte de moins de 10 personnes c'est
quasiment impossible donc on est là pour
résoudre ce problème
rapprocher les petits et les gros que
les gros et plus les petits parce que
bien sûr et c'est le cas c'est une
réussite savez la quatrième fois les
entreprises les petit retour ils nous
remontent sel et les gros soucis
d'accord et vous pouvez report retrouvez
le reportage complet de nicolas d'andré
patrick jacques de dixmude sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile google souhaite valoriser
l'inclusion via le numérique
pour cela la société a créé le google
une pac challenge un prix pour et des
associations ou entreprises à réaliser
ou conforter leurs projets mardi matin
se déroulait la cérémonie
et parmi les dix finalistes o'clock et
web force 3 2 centres de formation actif
dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui en france 13 millions de
personnes sont encore éloignés
c'est en partant de ce constat que
google a décidé de lancer son challenge
en france des prix récompensant des
projets valorisants l'inclusion
numérique
quid des talents savons qu'il ya des
organisations vraiment innovant est ici
qui ont des idées pour savoir être à
proximité de l'inclusion et on voulait
être à côté des meilleures idées des
entrepreneurs à travers le pays est
procuré l'aide dont ils ont besoin et de
trouver au mieux des volontaires pour
google parmi les 250 candidatures dix
projets ont été retenus finalistes
chaque représentant avait une minute
trente pour séduire le jury et 3 minutes
30 pour répondre à leurs questions parmi
eux deux centres de formation active
dans les yvelines o'clock une école qui
forme au métier de développeur web via
des classes virtuelles
c'est vraiment un gros travail à la
hauteur de l'enjeu aussi le pitch était
aussi beaucoup de stress mais bon
maintenant maintenant que c'est passé on
peut en parler de manière assez apaisés
on est on est tous content d'avoir fait
et web force 3 pour son programme de
formation numérique dédié aux personnes
en situation de handicap s'ils ne font
pas partie des cinq lauréats
comme tous les finalistes il remporte
tout de même une dotation de 150 mille
euros je pense que ce qui va être très
important c'est que en plus de la
subvention
de manière égale pour lesdits camps de
lady lauréats il va y avoir du mécénat
de compétences de google et dans
d'autres cas c'est assez important parce
qu'on a besoin d'une aide sur le plan
technologique pour construire ce
dispositif ordi forte chez les deux
grands gagnants sont le carillon qui
propose des solutions d'accès au
numérique pour les sans domicile fixe
prix du public et connexio qui aide les
personnes en recherche d'emploi à
accéder aux compétences numériques
premier prix du jury lutter contre
l'antisémitisme à travers l'art depuis
lundi le théâtre montansier se rend dans
des lycées pour lire des textes d'albert
cohen et primo levi auteurs touché par
le racisme
plus de 2500 élèves yvelinois sont
concernés par la démarche
mélanie poquet a assisté à l'une des
représentations albert cohen publie ses
mots en 1972 il relate une histoire son
histoire celle de ses 10 ans depuis le
18 novembre samir siad les lie à des
lycéens pour sensibiliser à
l'antisémitisme
on parle de lecture mais dans tous les
sens du terme c'est à dire à la fois une
lecture à voix haute
on fait passer les mots des auteurs mais
aussi une lecture dans le champ d'une
interprétation donc forcément et a
fortiori face à de tels textes on peut
pas rester indifférent
des lectures lancé par le théâtre
montansier une vingtaine de lycées lino
à l'accueil en novembre et en mars le
programme scolaire des lycéens faits qui
sont sensibilisés
avec tout ce qui s'est passé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale etc
il aborde le sujet avec plus de notion
donc c'est plus facile de diriger
vers eux d'autant que ces textes sont
très porteurs à albert cohen se joue un
primo levi qui témoigne de sa survie à
auschwitz lecture d'une heure suivi d'un
échange entre jamais comédien c'était
très émouvant
on voit que certaines personnes peuvent
vraiment se reconnaître dans le rôle du
petit garçon ça m'a touché parce qu'on
retrouve vraiment le cours de dents en
fait c'est vraiment la même chose que ce
que le prof ne raconte c'est vraiment
une histoire sincère ça ça dénonce
vraiment le racisme on espère bien
évidemment avoir l'occasion par la suite
de sensibiliser nos élèves à d'autres
types de discriminations et à faire en
sorte que le vivre ensemble se diffuse
le mieux possible
plus de 2500 élèves seront ainsi
sensibilisés sur ces deux périodes
d'intervention
après deux années de recul les actes
antisémites ont augmenté de 74% en 2018
comment présenter un film est donné en
spectateur l' envie d'aller le voir
c'est le rôle d'une bande annonce pour
la cinquième année la ville de bois
d'arcy a décidé de la mettre en avant à
l'occasion d'un festival et se déroule
le samedi 23 novembre à partir de 20
heures au théâtre de la grange
l'objectif est de présenter cet art
cinématographique un peu différent
durant toute la soirée animée par le
journaliste vincent perrot le public et
va pouvoir voter pour sa bande-annonce
préféré noter que le lendemain la
version junior se tient dès 15 heures
cette année on met en avant deux thèmes
principaux deux thèmes principaux
évidemment les 50 ans du cnc en kelly à
des bandes annonces qui sont restaurés
et retravaillé par le cnc qui monte est
présentée et animée en partenariat entre
vincent perrot et des services du cnc il
ya toute une thématique sur jean genet
jean dujardin avec une rétrospective des
différents films auxquels j'ai
participés à travers cette bande annonce
évidemment et aussi ceux qui vont
arriver
il y a trente ans l'organisation des
nations unies signe à l'unanimité la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfance pour son anniversaire le 20
novembre le service jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux a invité les enfants de la
commune a fêté leurs droits à l'hôtel de
ville
[Musique]
les petits envahissent l'hôtel de ville
de montigny le bretonneux pour fêter
lors de la le service jeunesse de la
commune a organisé cette journée
spéciale pour le 30e anniversaire de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
l'objectif de cette journée c'est de
sensibiliser les enfants déjà sur leurs
droits
on est quand même sur une tranche d'âge
6 12 ans je pense qu'ils ont besoin de
savoir et connaître leurs droits leur a
rappelé que eux aussi on sait bien aussi
un moment donné de savoir ce qu'on a de
faire un état des lieux un petit peu
dans ma ville qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que qu'est-ce qui est mis en
place de nombreux ateliers étaient
proposés comme ce débat mené par les
membres du conseil municipal des jeunes
les enfants sont amenés à recréer une
assemblée ils doivent réfléchir à des
solutions pour camille un garçon de 10
ans harcelé à l'école ça permet de
savoir comment le conseil municipal fait
pour rechercher des trucs pour s'occuper
de la ville plus loin un autre groupe
réfléchit sur le droit de bien manger en
recréant un des logo de l'unicef en
fruits
vous avez utilisé des fruits pour les
vitamines une pomme un quart de
clémentine des myrtilles de la cranberry
pour un personnage symbole et de leurs
droits
une journée de fête pour tous les
enfants messages importants et bien
digéré
[Musique]
l'observatoire départemental des
violences envers les femmes a révélé une
étude ans 700 mhz ni sur la prostitution
des mineurs les détails de nos confrères
via grand paris c'est une étude inédite
sur la prostitution des mineurs elle a
été révélée le 12 novembre en seine
saint denis par l'observatoire
départemental des violences envers les
femmes
on s'aperçoit que de plus en plus en
france des jeunes filles se prostituent
bien sûr les réseaux sociaux on n'est
pas le seul département mais comme on
est le département le plus jeune
c'est sûr que nous avons plus d enfants
à risque basés pour la première fois sur
des dossiers directement issues des
juges pour enfants
l'étude s'est penchée sur 19 cas de quoi
établir le profil des mineurs prostitués
dans le 93 1 sur 3 majoritairement des
filles à entre 13 et 15 ans 89% des
mineurs concernés ont été victimes de
violences par le passé
je lance qui dans 60% des cas provient
de l'un des deux parents ces données ont
été présentées pendant une journée à 800
professionnels du département
objectif mieux connaître le parcours des
jeunes pour mieux agir
l'intérêt de ces journées c'est former
les professionnels prévenir sur les
violences pouvoir identifier quand une
femme est en danger mais aussi comment
les aider comment les repérer et prendre
en compte vraiment ce fléau
parmi les pistes d'action une meilleure
surveillance des réseaux sociaux une
plus forte répression des proxénètes ou
encore l'ouverture de structures
spécifiques pour l'accueil et
l'orientation des victimes
aujourd'hui on estime qu'il ya entre
6000 et 10 mille prostituée mineure
en france c'est la fin de cette édition
on se quitte avec des images d'enfants
qui récitent leurs droits ce week-end
sur tv 78 on a le droit de rire
le droit de jouer j'ai le droit d'aller
à l'école
j'ai eu le droit de clocher on a le
droit d'être soigné a le droit de
s'amuser une dose l'égard des livres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]